- Écris jamais rien que
tu as pas vu toi-me e e e e e e,
ce que tu as vu.
- David Goudreault,
merci de nous accueillircrcrcrce
pour parler de Jack Kerouac.
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de la première fois que
vous avez etetetetetetetetetetes
a marqué et influencé?
DAVID GOUDREAULT, romancier
- "Sur la route", c'est
puis je pense qu'il faut le lire
à l'adolesccecececece qu'il y a
une espèce de mouvement.
Mais j'ai l'impression que
la consommation, les amis,l'l'lt
à l'adolescence, donc
je pense que c'est uauauauauauat
et, déjà, qui m'a donné envie
d'écrire. C'est peut-être ça
aussi, Jack Kerouac, hein,
"Le talent, c'est l'envie
de quelque choiiiii
l'impression que Kerouac avait
une envie de dire, une envie
l'écriture. C'est quelqu'unqui .
Kerouac s'est cherché
à trave t t t t t t t t t t t t,
à travers la religion,
à travers la spiritualité
incarnée dans ses relations.
on se cherche beaucoup.
Puis après, o o o o o o ou pas.
Mais pour moi, "Sur la route",
c'est un roman qui reste jeune
- Dans votre famille, on nerlrl.
- On parlait français
dans la cabane, la maison.
- C'est
Américain, parititititititit
le francophone anglophone
en terre d'une Amérique
- Moi, c'est un des aspects
qui me touchent, qui m'émeut.
son lien à notre langue, c'est
même son lien au territoire,
les Kerouac, du bas du fleuve.Iz
particulier, à un moment
particulier de s a a a a a a a .
Mais ce qui est clair, c'est
que non seulement il était
francophone de naissance,
il y a une partie de sa culture
qui est québécoise
et son côté francophone s'est
même transformé en francophilie.
il voulait écrire en français,ns
particulier, mais qui
l'habitait profondém
- L'histoire de "On the Road",
c'esatatatatatatatatatatatatatae
d'un ex-football player.
Puis, le gars qui "runnait"
la machine, c'était un cowboy,
- Il y a cette fameuse entrevue
avec Fer " " " " " " " "Sel de
la semaine" avec Jack Kerouac.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle vous dit,
le personnage? Parce qu'il y auk
Kerouac et le voir et l'entendre
parler en  a a a a a a a a a a ,
mais pour moi, elle n'es
si grande parce que Kerouac,
c'est d'abord un grand sensible
C'est quelqu'un qui avait
unr r r r r r r r r l'époque.
C'est pas pour rien que ça...
ça vient de lui, la Beat
Generation, c'est oui,le rythmed
"beat", c'est d'abord être
battu; lilililililililililililié
des gens battus, avec qui
la vie a été dure, qui peinent
à s'en sortir, qui passent
à une autre... Évidemment
, , , , , , , , , mais évidemme,
ses... ses tensions au niveau
relationnel, son rapport r r r t
pas quelqu'un pour qui la vie
a été simple. Et ça
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je veux parler du recueil
Ce sont tous les textesdededede.
C'est absolument extraordinaire.
Il faut lire ça. Il faut lire
ça. C'est tellement une belle
Jack Kerouac, pour ceux quintnt,
ça vaut peut-être la peine
que je m'y mhohohohohohohohohoh,
c'est un travail colossal qu'a
fait Jean-Christophe Cloutier
en allant non seulement
parfois même traduire. Je pense
qu'il y a eu un tr
lecture, un petit travail
de moine derrière ça.
écrivait beaucoup en françaisisr
qui est le sien. On a des notes,
même, sur "Sur la
ça a été aussi sur la route,
donc ce roman-là a été pensé
en français. Et donc, débarrassé
la langue maternelle, qu'il a
parlée jusqu'à l'â
il parlait seulement français
jusqu'à 6 ans à Lowell.
Et là, il arrive et il nous...i.
- Qu'est-ce qui vous...
attire à Lowell plutôt qu'à
New York ou à S
- Je connais toute la police.
- Et il y bobobobobobobobobobob,
où il dit : "Quand je me fâche,,
quand je rêve, je rêve
souven
rarararararararararararaille
Donc, cette sensibilité-là
est sienne, la raccecececececec,
toujours, les écrivains,
on s'en sort pas, c'est la mine
inépuisable de l'enfance,
" " " " " " " " " " " " " " " ,
écrit, je pense, en 1954.
-
Vous pensez qu'on va le lire
encore longtemps,
- Encore des centainesesesesese,
tant qu'il y aura des livres,
on va t t t t t t t t t t t t t.
Peut-être même immortel
d'un point de vue littéraire.
Et c'est cette construction-là
Kerouac unique et qui permet
non seul
se l'approprier, ils sont fiers
de Kerouac, les Américains,eveve
fiers aussi. D'ailleurs, moi,
je ne comprends pas qu'il y ait
pae e e e e e e e e e e e e e e.
(rires)
... le long de la route.
On devrait s'émerveiller,
quelques kilomètres plus loin..,
une immense statue de Kerouac,
quand même.
- On espère que cet appel
David Goudreault.
ésésésésésésésésésésésésésésie
et à la sculpture de Kerouac!
(rires) p p p p p p p p p p p ps
..............................
Mais il y a une chose que
des histoires. C'est tout.
♪